all right so in this module we will be
talking about inference rules so if you
remember so far we've been talking about
syntax and semantics and now we would
like to talk about how we can play
around with formulas and manipulate them
and apply inference rules on them i want
to talk about this diagram a little bit
more um for a second before jumping into
inference rules so let me let me go back
to my
my whiteboard here so
basically
what i've been drawing here is we
live in the syntax land and formulas
live in the syntax land so i'm going to
draw them like this so maybe i have
formula f1
formula f2
through maybe formula fn
okay
and then in the semantic slant
i give meanings
to these formulas right so so each
formula has a corresponding set of
models to it so so each one of these
formulas will correspond to something
that i'm calling models of f1
f2 might have another set of models
models of f2
and so on and you might have a bunch of
other ones so so let's say that i only
have like three of these actually let me
make this
that's three to make this simpler
so let's say i have f3 and f3 has
another set of models corresponding to
it autos of f3 okay
and then this part defines our knowledge
base right so we talked about knowledge
base being a set of formulas and and the
shaded area
corresponds to models of knowledge base
okay so this is models of our knowledge
base
so this is what we have talked about so
far so now we want to talk about what
inference rules really do
so if you have a set of knowledge in
your in your
knowledge base this set of formulas in
your knowledge base the idea of
inference rules is could you could you
basically apply a set of syntactic rules
on them and based on those rules i'm
going to call them inference rules
infer
something
a new formula here
so from
the formulas f1 through f3 that you have
could you infer a new formula a new g
that is just based on the formulas that
you have and based on like symbolically
manipulating on it manipulating them and
the question is could you make sure that
that g that you're inferring
actually has a model
that is a superset
of so this is model such as a superset
of models of of of kb because ideally
you want to be able to infer something
that just directly comes from the
formulas that you have so ideally you
would want to be in a situation where
models of g is going to be a subset of
models of kb and what does that mean
that means kb entails g
right so so could you have a set of
inference rules that end up giving you a
g and then you end up in a situation
where where models of g is going to be a
subset of models of kb so so could we
come up come up with uh those set of
inference rules and those set of g's so
that is the idea of inference rules and
what we're going to be talking about
today in this lecture okay
all right and that and that's basically
what this diagram shows so we have a set
of formulas each one of them correspond
to a set of models at the end of the day
i want to apply a set of inference rules
on these formulas and i want to be able
to come up with
models that is a super set of models of
my my knowledge base right would i be
able to do that
all right so
let's talk about that so so let me give
you an example what do i mean by that so
so let's say that uh i know it is
raining so in my knowledge base i have
that it is raining and then i have that
if it is raining then it is wet so rain
implies wet if i tell you that it is
raining
and if it rains that implies wet what
can you tell me from that just from that
knowledge
from that knowledge you should be able
to infer that well therefore it is wet
right it's raining and bringing implies
with so there it's got to be wet okay so
so that is the idea of infrastructure
could we like try to have a rule that
that tries to basically infer wet here
okay just based on the formulas
so so in general in inference rules we
have a set of premises we have a set of
formulas like rain and rain implies wet
and based on that we want to come up
with a conclusion in this case for
example that conclusion is is that it is
wet and then that defines like in
general like inference rules there's a
specific type of inference rule that
you're going to talk about it's a pretty
simple one and it's called modus ponens
okay so modus ponens is a very simple
inference rule and what it does what it
says is that for any prepositional
simple symbol p and q
if in my premises in my knowledge base i
have p and p implies q
that allows me to conclude q
kind of like this example that we saw
here
and you should think of inference rules
as very like syntactic symbolic views of
the world so so i basically just like
look at my knowledge base if i find
anything that matches form p and
anything that matches form p implies q
from that i should be able to infer to
you okay
let me put this here in the set of my
definition so now we are at inference
rules
and we are going to be talking about
modus ponens
so mode exponents is an inference rule
it tells us if we have p and p implies q
we can infer q based on that okay
all right
so in general inference rules we can
write them in in this way we have a set
of formulas f1 through fk and following
an inference rule allows us to conclude
g about it and depends on what inference
rule we are using modus ponens is an
example that we have just seen and again
these rules are applied directly on
syntax and they do not care about
semantics they don't care about what
raining means or what wet and raining
and the meaning between them actually
means right they're just applied on the
syntax on the formulas and that's kind
of the power of logic right like we
talked about these formulas as a compact
way of representing representing much
much larger meanings like exponential
meanings a lot of times and and now on
these very compact formulas we can apply
syntactic rules we can apply inference
rules and based on them we can infer new
formulas and and that have new meanings
basically
okay so so if i want to think about what
an inference algorithm does kind of like
a meta algorithm an inference algorithm
here does something of this form so so
we have an input that input is going to
be a set of inference rules we've talked
about modus ponens as an example but in
general i might have other inference
rules and what i'd like to do is i'll
like to repeat this loop until there are
no changes no more changes apply to my
knowledge base and what do i do i just
choose a subset of my of
formulas from my knowledge base and if i
can match my inference rule and and
infer a new formula g i will add g back
to the knowledge base and i keep doing
this until there's no more g's no no
more new formulas to be added to my
knowledge base okay so that is what an
inference algorithm does
and and one other definition here is is
this idea of derivation and proving so
what we say is is that a knowledge base
proves or derives a formula f
even only if if
even only if f eventually gets added to
knowledge base
so going back to to
let's say our definitions so now we have
a definition
of derivation
or proving
and you're going to use
so you're going to say a knowledge base
derives f and you're going to represent
that by this one line um one line kind
of symbol so so going back here we're
going to basically if i have f1 through
f3 in my knowledge base if my knowledge
base and like if i apply inference rules
and get a new g i would say my knowledge
base
is
deriving or proving g
okay
and so okay so on this magic land then i
have this idea of entailment
which might be different
from
what we have
in the syntactic land which is this idea
of inferring or proving
or deriving
so okay
all right so we'll talk about the
relationship between these two in a few
slides but let me just go back to go
back to talking about derivation a
little bit more okay so that is their
evasion that is proving so let's look at
an example let's say that i have a
knowledge base and in my knowledge base
i have that it is raining and i have
that rating implies being wet and i have
that wet implies slippery okay so the
question is can you can i apply the
inference algorithm on this modus ponens
using using just modus ponens and
rules how does how does that work let's
actually try this out using using the
system that we looked at in the
overview lecture so um let's say it is
raining
okay
so it says i learned something i can
look at the knowledge base so let's look
at what is in the knowledge base so
raining is the in the knowledge base
okay
i can say if it is raining
then it is wet
okay so it says oh i learned something
let's look at the knowledge base so it's
ha it has it is raining
it has raining implies wet that is that
is what this means because rain implies
width is equivalent to not rain or red
right because that's what implication
logical implication means
and then based on these two things it
actually derives wet it applies modus
ponens remember i have rain rain implies
wet what does modus ponens give me more
disponents gives me wet
so so i can derive it
let's add if it is wet
it is slippery
and let's see what that gives us so it
says i learned something let's look at
the knowledge base okay so we have a
bunch of things right so these are
things i added i said i added rain i
added rain implies wet i added red
implies slippery from the first modus
ponens that we applied we got wet
we can apply modus ponens on wet and red
implies slippery and we can get slippery
so this slippery is added
we also get another formula here rain
implies slippery
and modus bonus actually doesn't get us
that but but this this is using other
other types of inference rules not just
modus ponens and then if you if you
apply other inference rules you might
actually get rain implies like right
here okay
all right so so let's look at this exact
example here
all right so rain and rain implies wet
will will get us wet right
so we apply modus bonus again on red and
red implies slippery and that gets us
slippery and if the only inference rule
that we have here is modus ponens then
we have converged knowledge base is not
changing anymore we have derived wet and
slippery we have derived new formulas um
but uh
we we are we are basically we have
converged at this point and we can't
derive anything more okay so
so we can't derive a set of other things
here right like we haven't derived like
not wet probably a good thing that we
haven't derived not with because not red
is actually contradictory to our
knowledge base like it's actually not
true right so we shouldn't be able to
derive not wet that's a good thing
in addition to that we weren't able to
derive rain implies slippery which is
actually true right like if you think
about entailment and what is the truth
right like rain implies slippery is
entailed here but but we weren't able to
we weren't able to get that by just
applying modus ponens and and we will
talk about that in in general in a few
slides like why is it that we can't get
rain implies slippery and what can we do
to make sure that we get everything that
is entailed okay and and that is kind of
like the same question as like we see
here right like what is the relationship
between entailment and and and varying
and and deriving so derivation and
entailment how are they related are they
the same thing or are they doing
different things and does it depend on
the inference rule okay
all right so
so the density so far is we have
semantics semantics is really about
truth right it's about entailment like
about the meaning like what is actually
true when you say a knowledge base
entails f what that means is is that
models of knowledge base is a subset of
models of f and and no and and in terms
of like meaning like
that is actually what what the true
truth is on the other hand we've talked
about syntax in syntax we just do symbol
manipulation right using inference rules
we've looked at mode exponents as an
inference rule and then we have looked
at things like uh derivation so
knowledge base derives f
okay
so how are these two related let's talk
about that and that brings us to the
idea of soundness and completeness okay
so we're going to talk about soundness
and completeness
so let's look at this as an example so
imagine
imagine that you have a glass okay and
and every and things that go inside of
the glass are formulas
and imagine that anything that is inside
of the glass is the truth so what does
that mean that means that knowledge base
entails those formulas so so every
formula that is true is going to be
inside of the glass
so the idea of soundness is that if i am
applying inference rules if i'm from
running a bunch of inference rules the
formulas that are derived from those
inference rules i want to make sure that
they're also going to be inside of the
glass i want to make sure that they're
also true okay so so the idea of
soundness is that a set of inference
rules rules our sound if if
we have if the formulas that are derived
following that inference rule is going
to be a subset of the truth which is
which is that the the set of formulas
that are entailed by the knowledge base
okay so they're going to be inside of
the glass they're going to be true maybe
they don't fill the glass that's fine
but what this is telling me is that
anything that i'm deriving is still
going to be true i'm not going to derive
something that's absolutely false and
that's that's a very important uh
property that you want to have in in
general like you would want to have
soundness you want to have inference
rules that are sound because otherwise
we would be deriving things that are
absolutely false and and that inference
rule is not useful right like we want to
be able to derive drive things that are
at least true okay so that is this idea
of soundness
on the other hand there is kind of like
the the other side of the story which is
about completeness completeness is about
making sure that you're deriving
everything that is true again remember
everything that is inside of the glass
is true and the idea of completeness is
that you got to make sure that the
formulas that are entailed the formulas
that are inside of the glass are going
to be a subset of the formulas that are
derived so so what that means is that
your derivation rule make sure that that
you are you are getting all the formulas
that are true or even more than that
right like if you talk about
completeness without worrying about
soundness you might be able you might
even be deriving things that are outside
of this class but you want to make sure
that you are deriving everything that is
inside of the class too so everything
that is entailed and that's the idea of
completeness
okay
so if you put soundness and completeness
together you get a filled up with just
filled up class right you get everything
that is inside of the glass and just
everything that's inside of the glass
okay which is which is like everything
that is true everything that is entailed
okay so sadness and completeness is
about the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth okay so soundness
gets you nothing but the truth
everything that's inside of the glass
and nothing outside of the glass because
that would be bad right like you don't
want to get something false that's what
soundness gets you
completeness gets you the whole truth
make sure make sure that you get
everything that is inside of the glass
and and like nowhere is it like kept
empty right like you're driving on all
the formulas that are inside of the
class and that that is what completeness
gets you
in general you want both soundness and
completeness it would be awesome to get
both soundness and completeness and if
you if you get both of em then
entailment and derivation are equivalent
right like if you derive something
you'll make sure that it's equivalent to
the thing that that you're entailing
in practice soundness is more important
right because you don't want to derive
something that is false and maybe you
don't get all the truth but maybe that
is okay so so in practice you sound this
we prefer to get that
first and then and then push towards
completeness okay
so going back to here
so so soundness and completeness is the
thing that connects these guys together
so so
soundness
and
completeness
make sure that these two are equivalent
you should write that here too
okay so we talked about
sadness
and completeness
as things
that are relating
entailment and derivation okay
all right so
and then these are properties of
inference rules so the question is is
modus ponens
sound or is modus ponens complete what
can we say about modus ponens because
that's the only inference rule we have
seen so far okay
so remember modus ponens right like we
have rain and rain implies wet and modus
ponens gets a sweat so is that a sound
so so how do we check soundness
so to check soundness right sound this
is about the meaning it's it's about
checking if if it is it is actually like
inside of the glass right like the thing
you're getting is is actually entailed
so so how are we checking that we look
at models of rain models of rain is this
shaded area we look at models of rain
implies wet that is this shaded area
you take the intersection of them right
because models of these two formulas is
the intersection of these two models
that is the the darker area
and the thing you're going to check is
that if this darker area
is going to be a subset of models of
width is it going to be entailed right
like you're checking entailment because
that is about the truth right like that
is the thing that checks the truth so
models of wet is here
and then yeah this darker area is
actually a subset of models of it so it
turns out that modus ponens is actually
sound right like we are getting we are
we are inferring formulas that are
actually true okay
so it is sound
let's look at the difference in french
rule so i have a made up inference rule
that says if you get wet
and if you get rain implies wet can you
infer rain from that okay so you've got
wet and raining implies red is it
raining that's the thing you're checking
so this inference rule similarly i can
look at models a bit i can look at
models of that implies
rain implies wet
this shaded area is going to be the
intersection and that is not a subset of
models of rain right like as you can see
here that's not a subset of models of
rain so what that means is we don't have
entailment here right so so because of
that
this particular inference rule is
actually not sound
so all right so the nice thing about
modus ponens is is it's actually sound
but the next question to ask is is modus
ponens complete
and i want you guys to remember uh this
example that you looked at right like we
got a formula we got rain implies
slippery
and uh that wasn't from modus ponens
right like modus ponens wasn't able to
get that so this kind of gives us a hint
that modus bonus is not complete it's
not going to get everything that is
actually like entailing is actually true
but but yeah let's look at an example
i'm not going to do justice improving
like that modus bonus is not complete
i'm mainly just going to look at a few
examples so yeah so let's look at
another example here
so let's say our knowledge base is rain
and if it is raining or snowing it will
be wet okay
so so the question is um if if we can we
can infer
wet using using our modus ponens rules
so so first question is is it actually
that is it actually true that it would
be wet just like think about it like
intuitively think about it like
logically right like if you just think
about it intuitively you know it's
raining you know if it is raining or
snowing then it's going to be wet
so then it's it's got to be wet right
it's raining so it's got to be wet so
like if you just think about it
intuitively like you kind of like
realize that wet gotta be entailed here
right like let's meet like from meaning
perspective right like wet should be
included or should we should be able to
like get to it and and incorporate it in
knowledge base but modus ponens is not
able to infer that so why is it not able
to infer that because in modus ponens we
have this very specific syntactic form
of f and f implies g and then this
formula doesn't match that right like it
does have this or
and modus ponens doesn't really have ors
in it it doesn't really have any
branchings in it and and because of that
like i can't really apply i can't i
can't really apply modus 1 is here so
knowledge base here actually entails f f
is in tail it is going to be red but
syntactically using just mode exponents
i'm not going to be able to derive f
and then based on this example you can
kind of see that modus ponens is not
complete like we're not able to
derive everything okay
so one other thing i want to note here
is modus bonus is kind of interesting
it's just looking at positive examples
right like you you have a bunch of
positive positive clauses uh sorry
positive formulas and based on those
formulas you're able to infer something
positive and again infer something
positive and refer something positive
right it doesn't really have like these
fours or negations and then that is why
it's not able to it's not able to infer
this this particular property because we
have an or here because it's not able to
capture that and again it's like
applying things syntactically so it
doesn't care about meaning so how can we
fix this so the question is going back
here right like we just saw that modus
ponens sure it sound that is great but
it was
okay and ideally i want to be able to
get both soundness and completeness
because ideally i want my what i'm
deriving would be equivalent to what i'm
entailing i want both of them so a
question that we're asking now is how
can we fix that how can we fix the fact
that modus ponens is not complete okay
and and that's the topic of the next few
modules so we have two options to fix
this completeness first option is maybe
we should restrict propositional formula
so for positional logic maybe it is too
large if you're restricted maybe you can
restrict it to a specific set of
propositional logic that only has these
things that are called horn clauses
and under that scenario if you're
looking at propositional logic with only
horn clauses it turns out that modus
ponens is both sound and complete
the other option is maybe i don't want
to change my propositional logic i want
to keep all of her positional logic but
maybe i should be looking at more
powerful inference rules so modus ponens
seems pretty simple maybe there are more
powerful inference rules that i can use
and then specifically resolution is is
an inference rule that you're going to
be talking about which is both sound and
complete so next module we'll be talking
about horn clauses propositional logic
return clauses and the fact that modus
ponens is sound and complete and in the
module after that we'll be talking about
resolution and how we can use resolution
and the fact that it is
you